[Music]
i'm excited for you excited for devon
to see you guys both get the rookie of
the years man it's the only award you
can win
once
doc i want to start with you
as a rookie what do you feel
is most important in making the team and
trying to lead the team just
filling a role or in your case you end
up being a superstar
what do you feel was most important what
helped you along that way to win that
award
listen to the veterans and finally learn
as much as i possibly can create a guy
by mike torres
older gentleman and i get like a lot of
credit for my career basically i got
started because
he said to me you know when i'm not
pitching you're not pitching you're
gonna sit
next to me you're gonna go over hitters
he said look you're here for a reason
you belong here
carry yourself a quickly player take in
much information you possibly can
and i understand that it was a privilege
i mean obviously you earned to be there
but it's a privilege to wear uniform
once i made the team and got my feet wet
after about five six parts
i felt like i couldn't do this now i've
been learning to be here right good
has set a new major league record for
strikeouts
by a rookie pitcher his confidence
i know it's different now with the
analytics and all the scout reports
but you know what he don't have two
pitches so
that's all i had and i just thought
chase feeds the curveball you know
he'll show me that he can hit me then
i'll make
[Applause]
i got to see you up close and personal
when you first came up
you know behind jim told me who had just
signed a big contract with us
you get the call up you're living in a
hotel and i'm like i can't have this
so i brought you into the house you know
between wawa
and dishes being in my sink all the time
somewhere between that
and and you know the end of that season
i saw the confidence coming you and god
talked about that
the confidence i remember when tommy
first signed
that was my first season of minor league
ball so i had a decision to make right
then and there where
you know i'm like he just signed jim
tommy you know
do i i'm never gonna make it or do i say
hey they signed jim tommy whether i get
up with the phillies
or not my goal is to get to the big
leagues so
try to bang out as much as i could in
the minor leagues but when we got to
that situation
in 2005 i got called up because tommy
got hurt
forget about this one it is gone
grand slam home run ryan howard
i just said to myself you know i know
what i'm capable of doing
and i remember a reporter asking me they
said ryan do you feel like you've got
some big shoes to fill you know because
you're you're trying to fill jim tommy's
shoes i said no
because there's only one jim told me i'm
not jim tomy
i said if i do what i'm capable of doing
and i know that i can do
we'll be all right here's a shot
stop by howard great glove by the big
fella
i just put my focus into just going up
having fun
exuding that confidence like doc said
and by the way
we were also in a pennant chase so i'm
like i'm just trying to come up here and
kind of
play my role play my part try to help
this team win
as much as we possibly could and then
the rest
was restless history
now let's get to my next two young
fellas the futures
of the game kyle devin
2020 a year like no other what was
the mentality coming into a 2020 season
i was going into this
last season trying to prove that i
belong you know what i'm saying
i got a taste of 19 and i went into last
offseason
you know just trying to grind and get
better and then just kind of carry that
over into quarantine i think i took some
huge steps in
quarantine like with my change-ups and
everything i mean you saw how
it was working for me last year and then
you know just kind of
put it on the field showed everyone what
i could do change up look at that
pitch from devin williams you came out
and it was like season started
let's go by the time the season started
i was i was mid-season for him because
you know i never stopped throwing just
working on my craft
and then summer camp came and i just
kind of saw
the swings that were being taken at like
some of the stuff i'd throw up there and
like doc said like that just gave me
confidence
just to carry it over into the season
you know once you got
that first one out of the way i got the
second one out of the way
like you know i'm throwing well i'm
starting to build on build on the last
one and you know just kind of like it
was a snowball effect
so good you know what's coming you still
can't hit it
[Applause]
kayloo i miss the number 24 out there in
center field
taking home runs back back to the wall
goes lewis
and he brought it in beautiful catch in
big hits
i enjoy watching you play what you do
where you go about your game
and you're a game changer you know we
got a little bit of you this year but
you're a game changer when ryan stepped
in he was a game changer
it was like something was going to
happen when he came up to the plate
is that how you feel about yourself
that's how i feel about you i'm on
outside looking in but tell us what's
going through your mind and how
you look at yourself oh i definitely
feel as though
i'll view myself in that way and try to
mold my game in that way and learn as
much as i can
to continue to develop you know in a
complete way
got the opportunity to play center field
you know going into the year i was
looking at
you know playing one of the corner spots
we had to quarantine i went back
worked on my speed agility and came back
to summer camp and was able to split
time in center
and ended
[Music]
i'm excited for you excited for devon
to see you guys both get the rookie of
the years man it's the only award you
can win
once
you've only been ricky once you know
what i mean so to be able to
snag that award man i'm excited for you
guys i'm excited for the future of the
game
definitely going to be watching doc
watching you do what you did
and hear you say you only did it with
two pitches